welcome back to 8701
um our second part of the chapter and
qcd is on elastic
electron proton scattering
so elastic or electron proton scattering
in general has a long history
going back into the 1960s you know
famous examples are the mit slack or
flag mit experiment which led to the
nobel prize in physics for
jerry friedman henry kendall and richard
taylor
on 1990 and
the most recent and highest energetic
electron positron experiments were
conducted at daisy in hamburg
at the so-called hera ring
and we'll go back into those experiments
they're famous for
not just elastic electron positron
scattering but inelastic and deep
inelastic electron poisson polytron
scattering which
is going to be subject of future
lectures
um what we're trying to do here even
you know you might still wonder why this
is topic of a qcd lecture
um what you're trying to do is study the
structure of protons and the way to look
at this
is in this uh climate diagram is we're
using this photon here
to broke into the structure of the
proton
um you know we can start from from this
scattering process which we
already calculated and we derived the
mod scattering cross section formula
um but we really want to consider this
proton now as a blob
in elastic scattering we are not
destroying the proton so we
leave the proton intact in the
scattering process
we do know that the proton is not a
point length particle so if you want to
now
study the proton we have to take into
account that it's built out of
constituents
and that it has an extension it's not
point like anymore
and one way to do this is by analyzing
the fourier transform of the charge
density
functions remember the photon couples to
charge particles and so when we use a
photon to probe
a proton it probes a charge distribution
inside the proton so we build a fourier
transform
of the charge distribution um
and uh and and
then can extend the cross section uh
from a point like cross section
we are this fourier transform of the
charge distribution
great in electron position scattering
there is another point it's not just the
extension of the proton
but also the fact that the proton
carries recoil
and so we uh need to use two form
factors in order to describe the
cross-section
um fully um so let's have a look at the
amplitude again we can
start from where we left off with the
electron
positron scattering or electron electron
neuron scattering
and write down our matrix elements and
just now for the proton
what we do here is we modify the vertex
of the proton
and the modification is parametrized in
those two factors
describing describing the the cross
section or the matrix elements amplitude
with two form factors
one which just looks like a modification
of our spin
half particle you remember there's a
scammer factor
and then you know this is going to be a
number
and the other one is a little bit more
complicated there is a
powder matrix here and another number
and it's normalized by the mass of the
proton all right so this is just the
parametrization we haven't done much
physics here we have just parametrized
the distribution um if you then use this
we can as i just described um
calculate the cross section again using
those this very same parametrization and
get
to this formula here in the laboratory
frame
um this looks rather complicated but
if you uh go back to our form factor
definitions
and set this one the zero and this one
to one you get back in the same here
you said get back to our uh much
scattering result which we had before so
really extended
the discussion to extended extended
objects
and considering the charge distribution
and also the recall in the quarter
so this is great um historically
so this is not a new idea this has been
done for generations
historically the parametrization was
done slightly different
and so we introduced the linear
combination of those form factors and
those are
typically referred to as the electric
and the magnetic four factors the ge and
gm
this formula here and this is just
algebra going from
previous formula to this it's called the
rosen
blues thousand blues
um cross-section formula all right so
this is just if you find this in his in
in
particle physics booklets or nuclear
physics booklet
this is what's meant by this the only
thing we did here is
i extended the rosen the mod scattering
formula
using extended objects extend the charge
distribution to the
formula all right but
we have done that by using a full
transform of the charge distribution so
if we now measure the cross section
we can infer the charge distribution of
the total
and with that the radius the charge
radius of the proton this has been done
and we find that the rms the root mean
square of the proton charge is 0.81
femtometers uh so that's the charge and
this is
this measured charge is still today uh a
hot topic in particle physics because
it's measured distributions do not quite
agree with
the theory predictions so you see this
here parametrized
for this value of the put in charge the
theory and the global fit to the data
don't quite agree
you would have to go to slightly higher
values of the proton radius in order to
have
theory the previous experiments
so i leave it here the next lecture now
i
split this lecture in two parts the
elastic and the inelastic scattering the
next lecture will be
on inelastic scattering where we will
break the proton apart and learn about
the structure of the proton
you